Imagined you were alive back in the 1980s and were told the computers with Sim
take over everything from shopping to dating and the stock market,
that billions of people would be connected via kind of web,
that you would own a handheld device,
orders of magnitude more powerful than super computers.
It would seem absurd,
but then all of it happened.
Science fiction became our reality that we don't even think about it.
We're at a similar point today with genetic engineering,
so let's talk about it where it came from,
what we're doing right now and about a recent breakthrough that will change how
we live and what we perceive as normal forever.
Okay.
Humans have been engineering life for thousands of years.
Through selective breeding,
we strengthened useful traits in plants and animals.
We became very good at this,
but never truly understood how it works until we discovered the code of life.
DEOXYRIBONUCLEIC ACID DNA,
a complex molecule,
the guys of the growth,
development,
function and reproduction of everything alive information is encoded in the
structure of the molecule.
Four nucleotides are pad and make up a code that carries instructions,
change the instructions and you change the being carrying it.
As soon as DNA was discovered,
people tried to tinker with this.
In the 1960s scientists bombarded plants with radiation to cause random
mutations in the genetic code.
The idea was to get a useful plant variation by pure chance.
Sometimes it actually works too.
In the 70s scientists inserted DNA stuff.
It's a tobacco area,
plants and animals to study and modify them for research,
medicine,
agriculture,
and for fun.
The earliest genetically modified animal was born in 1974 making mice a standard
tool for research,
saving millions of lives.
Early eighties we got commercial.
The first patent was given for a microbe engineer to absorb oil.
Today we produce many chemicals by means of an engineered life like life saving,
clotting factors,
growth hormones and insulin.
All things we had to harvest from the organs of animals.
Before that,
the first food modified in the lab went on sale in 1994 the flavor saver tomato,
a tomato given a much longer shelf life where an extra gene that suppressed the
buildup of a rotting enzyme,
but GM food and the controversy surrounding them deserve a video of their own.
In the 1990s there was also a brief foray into human engineering to treat
maternal infertility.
Babies were made the carriage genetic information from three humans making them
the first humans ever to have three genetic parents.
Today there are muscled pigs,
fast growing salmon,
featherless chickens,
and see through frogs.
On the fund side.
We made things glow in the dark fluorescent to zebra.
Fish are available for as little as $10 all of this is already very impressive,
but until recently,
gene editing was extremely expensive,
complicated,
and took a long time to do.
This has now changed with a revolutionary new technology.
Now entering the stage CRISPR overnight,
the costs of engineering have shrunk by 99% instead of a year.
It takes a few weeks to conduct experiments and basically everybody with a lab
can do it.
It's hard to get across.
How big a technical revolution CRISPR is.
It literally has the potential to change humanity forever.
Why did this sudden revolution happen and how does it work?
Bacteria and viruses have been fighting since the dawn of life.
So-Called bacteria phages or phages hunt bacteria in the ocean phages kill 40%
of them every single day.
Phages do this by inserting their own genetic code into the bacteria and taking
them over to use them as factories.
The bacteria try to resist but fail most of the time because their protection
tools are too weak,
but sometimes bacteria survive and attack only if they do so can they activate
their most effective antivirus system?
They save a part of the virus DNA in their own genetic code in a DNA archive
called crisper.
Here,
it's stored safely until it's needed.
When the virus had tanks.
Again,
the bacterium quickly makes an RNA copy from the DNA archive and arms,
a secret weapon,
a protein called cas nine the protein now scans the bacteriums insights for
signs of the virus invader by comparing every bit of DNA at fines to the sample
from the archive.
When it finds a 100% perfect match,
it's activated and cuts out the virus DNA making it useless,
protecting the bacterium against the attack.
What's special is the cas nine is a very precise,
almost like eight DNA surgeon.
The revolution began when scientists figured out that the CRISPR system is
programmable.
You can just give it a copy of DNA.
You want to modify and put the system into a living cell.
If the old techniques of genetic manipulation where like a Mab.
Crispr is like a GPS system,
a summit from being precise,
cheap and easy.
Crispr offers the ability to edit live cells,
to switch genes on and off and target and study particular DNA.
Sequence six is also works for every type of cell,
micro organisms,
plants,
animals,
or humans.
But despite the revolution,
CRISPR is for science.
It's still just a first generation tall.
More precise tools are already being created and used as we speak.
In 2015 scientists used CRISPR to cut the HIV virus out of living cells from
patients and the lab proving that it was possible.
Only about a year later,
they carried out a larger scale project with rats that had the HIV virus in
basically all of their bodies house.
By simply injecting CRISPR into the ranch tails,
they were able to remove more than 50% of the virus from cells all over the
body.
In a few decades,
a crisper therapy might cure HIV and other retroviruses viruses that hide inside
human DNA like Herbie's could be eradicated this way.
Crispr could also defeat one of our worst enemies.
Cancer.
Cancer occurs when cells refuse to die and keep multiplying while concealing
themselves from the immune system.
Crispr gives us the means to edit your immune cells and make them better.
Cancer Hunters,
getting rid of cancer might eventually mean getting just a couple of injections
of a few thousand of your own cells that have been engineered in the lab to heal
you for good.
The first clinical trial for a crisper cancer treatment on human patients was
approved in early 2016 in the u s knows,
even a month later,
Chinese scientists announced that they would treat lung cancer patients with
immune cells modified with Crispr in August,
2016 things are picking up pace quickly and then there are genetic diseases,
there are thousands of them and they range from Marley annoying,
too deadly or Intel.
Decades of suffering with a powerful tool like CRISPR,
we may be able to end this over 3000 genetic diseases are caused by a single
incorrect letter in your DNA.
We are already building a modified version of CAS nine that is made to change
just a single letter fixing the disease in the south in a decade or two.
We could possibly cure thousands of diseases forever,
but all of these medical applications have one thing in common.
They are limited to the individual and die with them except if you use them on
reproductive cells or very early embryos.
But CRISPR can and probably will be used for much more.
The creation of modified humans.
Designer babies and will mean gradual but irreversible changes to the human gene
pool.
The means to edit the genome of a human embryo already exist there.
The technology is still in its early stages,
but it has already been attempted twice.
In 2015 and 2016 Chinese scientists experimented with human embryos and were
partially successful on their second attempt.
They showed the enormous challenges we still face in gene editing embryos,
but also that scientists are working on solving them.
This is like the computer in the 70s there will be better computers regardless
of your personal take on genetic engineering.
It will affect you.
Modified humans could alter the of our entire species because they're engineered
traits will be passed onto their children and could spread over generations
slowly modifying the whole gene pool of humanity.
It will start slowly.
The first designer babies will not be overly designed.
It's most likely that they will be created to eliminate a deadly genetic disease
running in our family.
As the technology progresses and gets more refined,
more and more people may argue that knots using genetic modification is
unethical because it condemned children to preventable suffering and death and
denies them the cure.
But as soon as the first engineered kid is born,
a door is opened that can't be close to anymore.
Early on,
vanity traits will mostly be left alone,
but as genetic modification becomes more accepted and our knowledge of our
genetic code enhances,
the temptation will grow.
If you make your offspring immune to Alzheimer,
why not also give them an enhanced metabolism?
Why not throw in perfect eyesight?
How about height or muscular structure?
Full hat.
How about giving your child the gift of extraordinary intelligence?
Huge changes are made as a result of the personal decisions of millions of
individuals that accumulate.
This is a slippery slope.
Modified humans could become the new standard,
but as engineering becomes more normal and our knowledge improves,
we could solve the single biggest mortality risk factor paging two thirds of the
150,000 people who die today will die of age related causes.
Currently,
we think aging is caused by the accumulation of damage to ourselves,
like DNA breaks and the system's responsible for fixing those wearing off over
time,
but there are also genes that directly affect teaching.
A combination of genetic engineering and other therapy could stop or slow down
aging maybe even reverses.
We know from nature that there are animals immune to aging.
Maybe we could even borrow a few genes for ourselves.
Some scientists even think biological aging could be something that eventually
just stops being a thing.
We would still die at some point,
but instead of doing so in hospitals at age 90 we might be able to spend a few
thousand years with our loved ones.
Research into this is in its infancy
and many scientists are rightly skeptical about the end of aging.
The challenges are enormous and maybe it is unachievable,
but it is conceivable that people alive today might be the first to profit from
effective anti aging therapy or we might need is for someone to convince a smart
billionaire to make it.
Then next problem to solve on a bigger scale.
We certainly could solve many problems by having a modified population
engineered humans might be better equipped to cope with high energy food,
eliminating many diseases of civilization like obesity in possession of a
modified immune system with a library of potential threats.
We might become immune to most diseases that haunts us today.
Even further into the future.
We could engineer humans to be equipped for extended space travel and to cope
with different conditions on other planets,
which would be extremely helpful in keeping us alive in our hostile universe.
Still a few major challenges.
The waiters,
some technological,
some ethical,
many of you watching will feel uncomfortable and fear that we will create a
world in which we will reject non perfect humans and quick select features and
qualities based on our idea of what's healthy.
The thing is we are already living in this wild tests for dozens of genetic
diseases or complications have become standard for pregnant women in much of the
world.
Often the mere suspicion of a genetic defects can lead to the end of a
pregnancy.
Take Down Syndrome.
For example,
one of the most common genetic defects in Europe,
about 92% of all pregnancies where it's detected are terminated.
The decision to terminate a pregnancy is incredibly personal,
but it's important to acknowledge the reality that we are pre-selecting humans
based on medical conditions.
There is also no use in pretending this will change,
so we have to act carefully and respectfully as we advanced the technology and
can make more and more selections.
But none of this will happen soon.
As powerful as Crispr is and it is,
it's not infallible yet.
Wrong edits still happen.
That's what,
as an unknown errors that can occur anywhere in the DNA and Mike go unnoticed.
The gene ad it might achieve the desired result disabling a disease,
but also might accidentally trigger unwanted changes.
We just don't know enough yet about the complex interplay of our genes to avoid
unpredictable consequences.
Working on accuracy and monitoring methods is a major concern.
As the first human trials began and since we've discussed a possible positive
future,
there are dark visions to imagine what a state like North Korea could do if they
embrace genetic engineering.
Could Estate Cement.
It's rule forever by forcing gene editing on their subjects.
What would stop a totalitarian regime from engineering an army of modified super
soldiers.
It is doable in theory,
scenarios like this one are far,
far off into the future if they ever become possible at all,
but the basic proof of concept for genetic engineering make,
there's already exists today.
The technology ready is that powerful.
One of us might be a tempting reason to band genetic editing and related
research.
That would certainly be a mistake.
Banning human genetic engineering would only lead to the science wandering off
to a pace with jurisdiction and rules that we're uncomfortable with only by
participating.
Can we make sure that further research is guided by caution reason,
oversight and transparency.
Okay.
Do you feel uncomfortable now?
Most of us have something wrong with them in the future that lies ahead of us.
Would we have been allowed to exist?
The technology is certainly a bit scary,
but we have a lot to gain and genetic engineering might just be a step in the
natural evolution of intelligent species in the universe.
We might end disease.
We could extend our life expectancy by Sentras and traveled to the stars.
There's no need to think small when it comes to this topic.
Whatever your opinion on genetic engineering,
the future is approaching,
no matter what.
What has been insane.
Science fiction is about to become our new reality.
A reality full of opportunities and challenges.
Videos like this would not be possible without viewed donations on patrion.com
if you want to support us expanding complicated stuff and maybe get your own
burden return,
you can do so here.
If you want to learn more about Crispr,
we put the sauces and further reading in the description.
More videos about the whole topic area will follow if you want to be notified,
but it happens.
You can follow us here.